thor et décider ensemble la manière de
la parole et à mesure gwenaëlle huet
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le premier ministre
monsieur le premier ministre en 2015
près de 520 mille salariés pour la
grande majorité des hommes ont ouvert un
compte pénibilité selon les quatre
critères en vigueur
le travail de nuit le travail répétitif
le travail en horaires alternants et le
travail en milieu hyperbare
six autres critères sont depuis entrer
en vigueur en juillet dernier
aujourd'hui 32 % des travailleurs
déclarent être soumis aux bruits 48 % se
disent soumis aux postures douloureuses
et 68% à des mouvements répétitifs
soit autant de travailleurs pouvant
prétendre au conte pénibilité un rapport
que votre administration a publié très
récemment
mais également très discrètement dresse
un bilan négatif de la mise en
application de ce dispositif estimant
qu'il est bien loin d'atteindre ses
objectifs
en outre ce rapport n'évoque à aucun
moment sa mise en oeuvre concrète et
encore moins son financement dans la
durée
le conseil d'orientation des retraites a
révélé que le dispositif était
clairement sous financés en raison même
de la possibilité de partir en retraite
anticipée
deux ans plus tôt cela entraînera à la
fois une diminution des cotisations et
donc des recettes et une charge
supplémentaire pour les régimes de
retraite
monsieur le premier ministre une
nouvelle fois vous instaurer un
dispositif sans tenir compte des
difficultés qu'ils génèrent pour les
entreprises vous avez pourtant déclaré
lors des universités du medef il y a
deux ans que vous aimiez les entreprises
je crois que celle inverse
vous ne les aimez pas vous les mépriser
vous alourdissent et leurs charges et
leurs contraintes
tout cela est très loin du choc de
simplification que vous prenez monsieur
le premier ministre
quand allez vous comprendre que les
entreprises ont besoin de souplesse pour
être compétitive et quand allez-vous
prendre enfin les mesures de relance et
la mairie
mail comme riz ministre du travail de
l'emploi la formation professionnelle et
du dialogue social
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
guen à lui ou elle guette
permettez moi tout d'abord de vous
rafraîchir quelque peu la mémoire en
c'est par un amendement porté par xavier
bertrand que dans la loi portée par
françois fillon qu'il y avait une
reconnaissance de la pénibilité à
travers une négociation dans les
branches
neuf ans plus tard cette loi n'était
absolument pas appliquée sur la question
de la pénibilité alors la pénibilité
tout le monde est d'accord bien sûr sur
le fond la main sur le coeur nous sommes
tous d'accord qu'il y as presque sept
ans d'espérance de vie
deux mois entre un ouvrier et un cadre
mais à partir du moment où il faut la
mettre en oeuvre
eh ben il n'y a plus personne nous nous
étions engagés à la mettre en oeuvre et
nous la mettons en oeuvre
en effet cinq cent mille salariés ont
bénéficié d'une reconnaissance de leur
pénibilité sur les 4 premiers facteurs
où en sommes-nous aujourd'hui il faut il
y avait une demande des organisations
patronales d'enlever la fiche
individuelle et donc d'apporter des
mesures de simplification
nous avons bien sûr entendu droit à
cette demande et donc nous avons
privilégié les référentiels de branches
dans chacune des branches est d'ailleurs
très concrètement la semaine dernière
avec marisol touraine
nous avons signé quatre arrêtés
d'homologation s'agissant de grosses
branches pense au commerce de gros
international aux écailles et
poissonniers quatre branches qui
concerne près de 265 mille salariés à
partir du 1er janvier
cécile autres facteurs seront pris en
compte mais aujourd'hui en effet il y a
dans certaines branches professionnelles
à la demande de certaines organisations
patronales de la rétention pour que les
référentiels ne sortent pas et moi je
vous le dis ici très clairement nous
sommes dans un rapport de force
politique vis-à-vis de ces branches ou
les référentiels sont prêts parce que ce
sont les chefs d'entreprise